Film Courage: What are the steps to
developing and building a character?
Robert: The steps to developing and building a
character I have found has evolved greatly for
me but first it was to sort of tap into my own
subconscious of just how do I see this person
I'm super visual and so if a character comes
out I can see that person in all detail
and so it's first to like
understand what that vision is
and then second it's to ask myself who do
I know in the real world that's like this
and to use that as a sort of reflection of
of what I see versus what's in the real world
and and then also to compare it to other movies
how has how is a character like this shown up
in other films and what's worked and what hasn't
and also to ask what is the role of this character
in the story and and it's it's all of those but
but primarily it's to draw it back to reality is
and not just not just reality but also
to put it in your own frame of mind is
if I was in this position what would I do or if my
very best friend who's very akin to this character
was in this situation what would they do and I'm
also just a strong proponent of of speaking to
those people right like if you have a character
that's that's a bit of a match with with somebody
hanging out with them picking up on their
eccentricities and the ways that they say things
and and maybe even calling them up and saying
look if somebody said this to you what would your
response be you should get a release if you have
them literally providing lines for your script but
but those types of things I found is that
you just get so much nuance and and unique
dimension by following those steps that
it's something I try to always employ
here's what the screenwriter of Strive Sha-Risse
Smith said about you I don't know how it's
possible but physically and emotionally Robert
understands what Kalani the main female
protagonist in Strive is going through
and that is what's important so can you
explain how you have empathy for characters
so in reading scripts I always ask myself
is this a story that I know and what was
ironic about Strive is that or I guess different
about strive is that it was set in Harlem and in
a world that on the surface I shouldn't
understand and isn't my story that said
there were some core aspects of that character
that I really felt connected to so much so that
not just not just Sha-Risse but also people who
saw the film came up afterwards and they're like
how how did you tell this story and it felt first
because because I sort of understood the pain of
what that character was facing but but secondly
because I spent a lot of time understanding and
being in that neighborhood and and I guess maybe
that is a bit of the documentarian side but
but literally being there doing doing
I want to call it research because it's
it's it's not that but just understanding those
people that way of life we moved to Harlem two
months before we started production and that
was for the sole purpose of understanding that
neighborhood and what you immediately realize
about Harlem is it is a it is a close community
and it is a community that looks to lift one
another up and and there is so much creativity
and and so much compassion and so it was the
little things that we witnessed and on the good
side and the bad side that we then really tried to
bring into the film so that it felt like at first
and foremost a Harlem movie and then also one
about about the main story main character Kalani
how do you do that whether as a documentarian
or for a narrative film how do you soak up
the environment of the location that you'll be
shooting I think it just comes with like observing
being being quiet or or when you need to be or
asking a ton of questions when you need to be
and then there's always those guides that sort
of will take you into the world and so asking
hey what is it like to to be a in this
neighborhood and then going with a and walking
through and seeing how people interact with them
and one of our main actors on the film was just
not connecting with the character early on and I
had him shadow a and and the things that he was
just able to to pick up about their interaction
was just such a literally walking into a different
world right so his imagination just can't fill in
all of that detail that that is is actually there
so that was extremely beneficial and still
he wasn't fully there and so I sat him down
not to over simplify it but I was like you smile
too much like this is these are this is serious
and and so sort of I see I see what you mean
like and so we dialed that back just to kind
of craft the character that was a reflection
of the world that it was in so people when
this actor walked around with the crib people were
scared of the like the the body language and the
the reaction was they were fearful it was so much
respect paid to this person that whether they were
crips or whether they were bloods they would
cross the street and and shake his hand and not
not bow but sort of lower their it just it was it
was clear that this was a very respected person
and on the opposite side that he also respected
the community and that he was there looking out
for people and checking on people and and it's
those it's an understanding of those relationships
and sort of why these people are there and and
and how they interact with the community that
ultimately sort of brought the spine out of the
character that then made it playable how do you
create characters that are raw that are memorable
mesmerizing I think that is a very difficult
question to answer a very difficult thing
to do we certainly interact with people that
we have found like that's quite a character right
like wow like I would never have thought to think
of the world like this or to say something like
that and that can come out in two different ways
it can either come on literally trying to get as
much of that person into onto the page and into
the character it can come up come through just
having a phenomenal imagination and channeling
something like that or it can come in having
a really good actor and asking them to bring
themselves asking to run improv there's certainly
I was just watching a thing about Jonah Hill on
Wolf of Wall Street and there was so much improv
that he brought and that's Jonah right like that's
him coming on and so I think it it's there's
multiple ways to do it but it's it's something
that needs to be very concerted to to be able to
pull off successfully so the way that a director
would try to soak up a location same thing with
trying to soak up various sort of composites of
people indeed yeah in Harlem or even around la
I've certainly met like very dynamic characters
and and so yeah it would be first asking them
permission can I can I lean on on you and sort
of put you into a into a film and who you are and
and that can come early in the writing process or
that can come from taking one particular character
and wanting to kind of spice things up a bit and
reworking the script or just hiring that person
and saying look like these are the lines but we
ultimately hired you write the objective of
each scene and and that's the way we're gonna
run it we're gonna run it as you and accomplishing
this objective to to move the narrative forward.